all right hello again everybody
we are doing another round of reviews of
well
geometry and graphics functionality
heading for version 13 of orphan
language
all right so where are we going to start
here
i think we're at region transformations
and going down
okay so i want to do this we need to
wait for the folks who are involved with
geometric tests so let's go do graphics
first okay let's come back up and do
these other things and is there any any
more news on voronoi mesh in 3d
nope
i mean time's running out so
okay
the the news is it's arriving right
yes that's correct the train is arriving
at the station
yes hopefully yes
okay
one of these days you're going to say
just arrived because
um
okay
all right
we had started talking about this last
time point light and so on
um
and we had talked about putting it in
style right which which works now
correct
but i think we need we need to
understand some things about coordinate
systems and so on right because i i
heard some discussion about um
um
the fact that the image 3d coordinate
system is different from these
right
so let me just understand what
coordinate system
when
didn't we have some kind of um
projective coordinate system that we've
used for millions of years for okay what
coordinates is viewpoint in let's start
with that
it's in the user coordinates correct
can somebody answer that
roger can you i mean don't go there i
think it supports more than one
coordinate system you see here down
there it's a table there's three
coordinate systems supported
and i think viewpoint supports
more so this is consistent with those
the the coordinate system's okay let's
take a look
none of that's actually changed here
it's the same as before
no
no no you see this is something
different i thought this was different
and it is in fact different
the viewpoint is given a special scaled
coordinate system in which the longest
side of the bounding box has length one
see what i'm saying
yeah
so how does this relate to that in other
words if i want my light
if i'm
if i have a miner's lamp on
and i want to look from a viewpoint with
a point light how does that work
what
so
i mean so for the new light i mean this
new directive nothing changed i i don't
care about that i'm asking the question
we've got viewpoint which is set and one
coordinates well we haven't given it the
viewpoint coordinate system a name so
you can't use it very widely i
understand that but
apparently this wasn't thought about
right but
is what i was going to say that you know
the point coordinate system the point
you have that i can point light is
mapped with the cartesian coordinate
system of the graphic not related to the
viewpoint i'm aware i'm aware
i'm i'm asking
what
um
uh but you understand my question
right
is there a reason i don't know and
viewpoint was was put into version one
why is it that viewpoint does not use
user coordinates
because it's going to be
yeah i think it's
it's because
these are
intuitive they're sort of a scaled
coordinate system
basically
inconvenient for most people yeah
exactly
right i mean i think it's just that if
you're doing if you're just
if you're if you're not really
especially in version one if you just
want to show something you know you're
not caring about the details that much
and you just want to be aesthetic
then yeah you just want to do it based
on the user user or you know the
viewpoint
uh coordinate system and also that you
know for plots almost always you care
about the viewpoint uh the viewport you
know coordinate system you don't care
about the actual graphics
coordinates for instance if you would
have any function that have a
singularity it would depend on the data
is that cut off and such things okay
okay okay fine right so now explain why
point light
works differently
it works exactly the way it has worked
there's no different i mean it's the way
it's worked all along
but
there's no
that design discussion we should have
had inversion
uh long time ago
i think the point is that something like
point light you know
i feel like the other the the like
things like viewpoint
is is more about
like
like like it's more about just getting a
generally roughly aesthetic image versus
i want a light at exactly this position
it has to align with my graphics right i
mean it's a difference between like if
you're just trying to get you know a
three three light you know whatever it's
called three light you know lighting
setup versus if you actually want to
have a light at a particular spot
relative to your you know objects okay
but in that i just want the lights at
roughly the three lights set up don't
you want viewpoint like coordinate
systems to specify you want
scaled being scaled
which is different from viewpoint
i think sometimes this and sometimes
this
there's no union i mean the the
viewpoint
uh
the two cameras possible the viewpoint
camera you can't go inside of the
graphic you have to be outside of the
graphic so it's a very special camera
that views the world like kind of like a
specimen that you look up from the
outside right
and what happens so viewpoint with
numbers less than one simply doesn't
work is that correct
yeah i think so no no it does work but
it distorts everything because if you
specify a few angles
yeah it's trying to find a view angle
that incorporates the whole object
and so that goes very simply very weird
yeah okay but but the thing i'm asking
with point light and so on okay
independent of the defensiveness of the
fact that it's a you know it was already
implemented in a different way
explain why
the coordinate system you want in other
words if i wanted the light to be coming
from the place where i'm looking at the
graphic from how would i do that
did you see what i'm saying
i think that
well
you usually you place the light relative
to the relatively to the scene
so that's kind of here but the answer is
you don't know how to do it
right no no we don't want to do it but
it's too complicated we if we wanted to
make that super easy i don't know if
it's a good idea to make it easy maybe
it isn't
in which case we have to introduce a new
coordinate system right i'm just trying
to understand what we actually have you
know you know what it could be a
statement of viewpoint scaled
coordinates
right but as opposed to image scale but
what about the viewport is that yet a
different concept
no the viewport
is the port is a 2d thing
um
the port is usually a 2d thing
you know so it's if you think of the the
frustum
yeah the point camera right and you see
like this square cone going out yep and
you have the frustum which is sort of
you know that delineated by two planes
yeah yeah and the port is the thing that
gets projected onto that front
piece you know that cone that's the port
right
okay so i don't know why we brought up
the port here but it's
okay well actually i mean that's a very
basic question i mean
don't the lights i mean if you're not
using point like don't the lights like
follow the camera like if you rotate
things
the lights
the lights don't move too right unless
you use point light does this question
make sense
yeah the question is what is the
coordinate system in which the other
light sources are
the point is as the camera moves do when
do the do the lights
yeah that's the question the directional
light what coordinate system does
directional light usually use
guys
guys do you understand the question
right
charles roger please
okay do i need to
do i need to try it i need to try it
okay the question is if i have a 3d
graphic right
i say plot 3d
it doesn't follow the camera the light
moves with the scene yeah so if you
rotate it
wait i think it follows the camera by
default like if you just do you just do
this
yeah and if you rotate it don't don't
move around a little bit so it depends
if it's scaled or not right so
okay so with these lights
yeah the shadows are changing
well here look maybe i want to do a
cuboid or something
i mean you can see in there okay
you want to send something in
no i mean this will work too but if you
just look at you know that face is lit
and now if you rotate it a different
face would be left
right so the light is off here
in the coordinate system
that is has nothing to do with the
rotating coordinate system of the object
itself the lights are fixed outside of
the specimen box
correct guys
is that correct
charles rogers yes that's correct for
the default light and this is the french
okay so are you hiding something here i
mean the what what happens for these
lights
okay what is the default lights lighting
what is it in terms of these symbolic
objects
so is in the documentation i don't know
the value explicitly no i understand but
but it's the same coordinate system so
it's the lighting
okay so like standard what is that
in the default positions what are the
default positions i think you can do
absolute options and get it
oh i think it's documented under the
gene you know generalization extension
we have all the list of automatic accent
and neutral values there
well here if i just take this and i say
absolute options
and then lighting
useless
okay where do i look
under generalization
something is wrong with this version as
i've been reporting for the last two
weeks about scrolls is it the scrolling
yeah i mean they found the memory leak
bug that you anticipated it would be
amazing
um okay
it's equivalent to the following
explicit setting
okay
so what would this be in terms of the
symbolic primitives
so it'll be exactly the you'll be
exactly the same
but the only difference is that now is
more redirective so
you will do a
graphic 3d
ambient light
bracket followed by the caller okay so
this is an image scaled coordinates so
what does that mean image scaled
coordinates
what why does that do the thing that
we're seeing it doing here
what does image scale mean where is
image scale locked down to is that is
that relative to the viewing
that i have in the notebook
relative to the bonding box right or the
final display
of the displayed image image
right as opposed to the graphics object
which is flapping around moving around
here right
so if i were to change this
so let's say i would do it to do this
okay i'm just going to remove that there
for what it's worth we got bret for this
current conversation in case he's
helpful
okay so i am
irreducibly confused here okay so then
we've got two cases here
okay so now we're moving it around
and
i see
the
that sphere does not appear to change
its does not change its appearance
because the lights are locked relative
to my eye
is that correct guys
it looks that way
okay
charles
are you responsible for this fun who's
responsible for this functionality
it's me
okay
can you explain the answer here is this
this is not is is locked relative to the
notebook correct
and to my eye and that's why this is not
changing its appearance is that correct
right relative to the bounding box yes
no no no what are you saying bounding
box this is a bounding box this box here
you're not talking about that bounding
box you're talking about the bounding
box which is defined by this right
exactly yes the x y is relative to that
okay what's the z
z is into the page and out of the page
is that correct
exactly orthogonal to the plane of the
display okay so image scale has x going
across here
y y going up here and z coming out of
the page is that correct
yes
okay
and the scaled is it's just as a
fraction of the size of the bounding box
or something
yes
you just said bounding box which is
totally confusing you mean the graphics
box
the graphics right
right okay so this is now moving around
and the lights you know it'd be really
nice and is there an option which
actually displays the lights
no but
um
actually
i build prototypes for this long time
ago i think we need to come back to that
um why don't we at least have a wfr
function that will show you the lights
yeah but someone needs to write it
i think we should develop it i mean yeah
but it's not good enough that's why it's
not out i mean i know but for wfr you
could just have little spheres at the
position yeah no
lights are outside of the box typically
yes that's true
well so you'd have to have arrows going
to the lights
that's a mess
okay
you could have like a diagram that
showed
where the lights were
relative to some representation of that
graphic
sure
right the graphic has to be small
in its specimen box so to speak
and okay
no but there are other things like that
you also want to see where the camera is
and where the frustum is they're all
kinds of these
right
set up things that i think are useful to
do
right so this is essentially another
view of graphics it's a wrapper
it's called you know uh graphics
arrangement or something where you can
say graphics arrangement of graphics 3d
and graphics arrangement is a
is the kind of
is formats as
um
right
yeah it will show you
it can show you these additional objects
and you kind of typically
want like little coordinates like you
want a sort of an xyz you know axis
on the camera so you see where it's
pointing and which you know where's the
x y z axis going and you can have the
same for some of the other elements like
a directional light it's kind of useful
to see
uh point light doesn't matter so much
but some of the others are all right
okay so i think i understand this i
think i'm good with this is there
anything else that we need to look at
are there any special features here
so directional light
it comes from infinitely far away i
understand by the way i really hate it
when people do this in documentation
if we unless there's a really good
reason you should copy that stuff into
this
okay that's the um rbs commenting
specify ambient diffusion specular
highlights i believe we have that
capable of yes yes
um
and uh ethan is asking for method arrow
reaches do we have a method our array
tracing
no
not yet
we have prototypes of it but no
okay
okay all right should i look at nothing
else in these um
i mean sorry the directional light
from the vector from point one to point
two okay but but it's it's a um
what
it's projective that is all that matters
is the direction the thing is infinitely
far away it's like the sun
why is that projective
because it only cares about the
direction of the vector it does not care
about the
the uh uh you know where where it is
relative to the object right right right
it doesn't
yeah
no absolutely there's no attenuation no
no
intensity falling off or anything like
that
is that the spotlight yeah there is
what is it is it inverse square
yes
it's not great but that's what these
graphic shaders do
what do you mean it's not great i mean
inverse square is inverse square yeah
but it's kind of hard to specify
that last case att attenuation yeah
you see that that's an inverse square oh
boy
fine
are there formats for people storing
lighting specifications
you know when people make a movie and
they have you know a whole team that
does the lighting for a scene
i mean in
an animated movie
is there a specification how do people
carry those things around
you know what i'm asking have you looked
i haven't looked at that a recent we
know that there's just like that for
shaders but the question is is that for
lighting setup in principle there should
be
well
most of those form also carry the light
yes
but also
in principle
and
you know when we get more advanced
rendering but there's more
types of lights like area lights this is
an example of something we don't have
because then you need
uh basically global lighting
calculations
right but these are already pretty
complicated specifications what does
maya do for example how does it carry
around this information well i mean okay
so there are a bunch of you know 3d
formats like i know autodesk has fbx i
think which i think we also support to
some extent which can which can store
you know the lighting configuration
but that's different from like the
shaders and it's different from like the
you know what's the attenuation function
that's just oh i've got a this light
here and that light there and so on
but so if we
send one of our scenes to fbx format
will we expect that it will preserve and
then we import it again we export this i
mean if i say export string
of line 4
to um fbx is that the name of the format
yeah i mean i guess that could work
although it's pretty i don't know i
think fbx is like technically
proprietary i'll always do support some
things with them
like this
what is this
is a current failure window
okay
okay fine but but we would expect that
this
were we to export this
this would losslessly be able to make
the round trip is that what we expect or
not
yes when we are able to do that with
high fidelity currently we just support
the geometry right and you know the
third version we are going to support
the texture and after texture lighting
okay
there is there isn't a separate thing
like a you know like a pem file for
lighting or something where you just
have the lighting information
so for some formats they do have some
stuff a little like that it's like for
example with obj uh they have a separate
mtl file for the textures although i
don't think they have anything for
lights i mean the basic thing is that
most 3d formats are just restoring
models and maybe their textures
but basically lights are just thought of
as other objects in the scene and there
aren't that many formats for
representing like a whole scene
um
right so yeah fair enough
okay is there anything else we should
look at with these lighting
specifications this all looks like a
nice thing
i mean some of this looks
but that's it for now okay rbs on our
livestream is commenting about fong
illumination we certainly have fong
fong shading
but i guess
we don't call it that i don't know
what is the default
lighting
model we are using on material shading
can emulate all that is more advanced
emulator for that
okay
i thought we were using guru
shading by default
we have the capability to do phong
shading with an arbitrary exponent right
we've had that for like decades
all right okay
well i don't think um tim and brett for
the lighting stuff so i think i could
let youtube go now
unless they have any further comment
about this but wait a minute what about
these three point lights and things like
this
and then the lighting effects only the
shaded material what what is this hold
on
hold on what is this here
material shading is a style you know
it's it's like a color right
yes but
what is the
what this is saying is okay so let me
just understand what this is
okay so let's uh this is just a display
list so what right now it's not working
but so there is always so our you know
directional light have you know
fixed argument parametrization right but
we can also extend it to support for
example the three-point light where we
have automatically
hold on hold on
somebody capture that message please
yep
okay sorry go ahead so
three point light is three directional
lights
okay so if i got rid of this
it won't work i don't think we it's okay
because of because of just the way
because of today it doesn't work is that
right
right so it's an extension we're
planning to add for directional light
where you can take a string tripoint
light and then we actually
instantiate it into
you know the three different point
lights but what does this have to do
with material shading
this this is you're saying if i do this
then
this will affect only the sphere
and it's the same as saying style sphere
material shading gold
you know directional light three point
that will affect just that style
delimited thing correct
yes
okay and what you were saying there
about directional lights
is if i have that
is those are named types of directional
lights correct
yes
and and
doesn't lighting
in general have a have a bunch of named
configurations
yes
okay so what's the relationship between
those
so those are string names for lighting
itself
i'm confused here there's a string named
three point for the whole lighting
option what's the relationship between
that
and the string name for directional
light
no it's the same thing this is a this is
a global option
the one is an inline
directional light and three-point all of
these are directional lights
okay let me ask this question
you know in the theater lighting
business for example or well
the two models would presumably be well
three there's that there's photographers
you know taking pictures of like people
and there's
taking pictures of you know random food
or specimens or whatever else
i'm quite certain that there are names
for lots of lighting configurations and
all of those different uh areas is that
true or not
yes true and the three-point is one of
those
it's a set it's a set of lights
okay
with which are all white
yes
but so so if i look up
you know
if i look up um i don't know theater
lighting configurations or something do
i find
um
you know is there some standard way that
those are described i just don't know
anything about this yeah you've got a
main light and a uh secondary light and
a backlight
okay
it's it's for mainly for photography for
studio photography
but
i mean you know
if i just go to the web and i look this
up i see pictures like this
oh stephen this is a whole story
okay then you want them to change over
time too
right
okay
fill lights
yes
yes
this this is a whole
this this is a whole story i understand
that but so what i'm trying to
understand is you know we're gonna have
some named examples
right of
well like like for example
you know
okay
the thing i'm trying to understand is
where are we going with this is there
going to be some repository of named
lighting configurations or are we going
to have some lighting configurations
here or what's the idea
we i right now we're not pushing it i
mean i had long time ago but right now
we're not pushing this farther for right
now
so far like accent and three-point those
were designed specifically for
shaders
okay i mean but this seems like it's
rather low-hanging fruit
oh am i wrong i mean in other words in
other words we can just incrementally
add you know if there's a named
configuration of lights that's used for
this or that
you know these are things we don't need
a repository we don't need any we don't
need a suppository
or anything
but okay with that so explain how you're
going to do this
we're not doing it i mean but so that's
the answer you're not doing it so if
you're not doing it if we had you know
the question is if if
users were interested in adding a
collection
of different lighting configurations if
this is even useful how would they do
i
it
for one thing i'm not sure how many
different named lighting configurations
there are like i mean looking this up
just now
it's like yeah there are a lot of
different configurations of three-point
lights and there's some mild
modifications and so on but i'm not sure
it's like i don't think there are 25
different
famous you know
lighting configurations that we should
all right okay fine so it's not the case
so when people
specify i mean you know
when people come in
to photograph some random thing and they
bring all these lights
right
i mean we've
we've definitely got people in our video
team for example at the company who
would know the art know how this works i
do not know and you know when you come
in and people say oh i'm going to set up
all these lights so photographer comes
in and sets a bunch of lights they have
names for all those lights all the light
all the they have names for the
functionality of those lights like key
lights and things like this right
which is not what we're doing here
i mean i also think that i'm not sure
how automatically i mean you can i'm not
sure how automatically you can do a lot
of that stuff anyway because it's like
if you have some complicated graphics
scene
then the point that the person that the
photographer is doing when they're
setting up all the lights and they're
getting the basic three lights and then
they're also you know trying to be like
oh i want a little more key light on
this object i want a little less on this
object yeah i understand i mean that's
not gonna happen automatically all right
okay fine i mean so you're saying it's
like saying in an image what's in there
oh let's have seven standardized names
of images which would not make any sense
you're saying that lighting the
specification of lighting yeah all right
well fair enough
um
let's see the various comments here
about
uh
comment that we should have fong
shading as a name somewhere you can find
if we don't we should have that we
should check that
ultra is asking is the chronos standard
gitf supported what is that a standard
for what is that anybody know what that
is
but chronos is the standardization group
that works on renewed opengl standard
among other things
the the the thing that i don't know what
they what was that thing that they
mentioned loading of scenes for for um
3d asset delivery
well so the jhf is one file format in
the list of what will support
so gitf we have it
no not yet
okay but it's it's one of the ones we
intend to have yes
okay
and it's a 3d object format is that
right yes
oh i see it says loading 3d scenes and
models and applications okay
yup
okay
that looks like a useful thing
all right
interesting seems rather recent okay
uh
alembic format what is that
anybody know what that is
where are you looking i mean you're not
somebody screamed yeah
um
i don't know what this is somebody has
to look this up separately
this looks like a
format for
some kind of database thing i don't
understand this
okay
um
open game engine exchange
we know what that is
nope okay so somebody um who's is brady
can you collect these things yeah i am
okay
send them out
obvious talking about various kinds of
shading we have these we've had them for
years flat grow phong shading we have
them
we have all oh i see the fun elimination
model is a lighting model it can be used
for all three okay i was confused by
that
yeah phong shading i mean phong
shading means that you interpolate the
normals
across
the
um
like a triangle
and then you compute
um you run the shading equation on each
point inside of there if you use guru
shading you interpolate the colors that
you use
uh
but you don't interpolate the normals so
it's a little bit simpler and that's
what what opengl was running
okay by the way alembic seems to be an
ilm
and
sony an image works
that's presumably the original
that used to be
oh gosh what was specific data images is
that the company that became
i don't know i lost track of what turned
into what
um okay that seems to be another file
format here
thank you
um
okay let's see uh doug is commenting on
view vector can be used to specify the
absolute coordinates of the camera
yes
that's the other camera
viewpoint has this funky coordinate
system which views everything as a
specifier view vector allows you to put
the camera anywhere
i see i see okay
all right let's change topics here okay
so so the the conclusion is there's
nothing more to do on we we have certain
standard lighting configurations we
don't think there's a value to any other
ones although there might be ones that
we could invent that will be useful for
viewing certain kinds of objects
but that there's nothing out there in
the general world that we could that
would be familiar to people that we
could uh sort of use the name of is that
correct
yep
okay all right changing topics thanks to
folks who are here for the um
uh for the lighting discussion we are
now changing topics to region congruent
and related things
good see ya
bye
okay michael have you seen these
functions
region congruent etc no
okay
so
geometric test
has a has a congruent testing thing
right i think so
it has similar incongruent
congruent there we go so what's an
example of what region test would take
as input
would take like
a disk
and a disk is that what it test takes
and then congruent
doesn't seem like
no i don't think it will start syntax
by the way
for a function which has just an
unbelievable number of of um
of capabilities the fact that it only
has like eight examples it's really a
bit disappointing yes we could add some
more
i think there should be in a list
the two disk
yeah right okay so geometric tests the
two lists the two disks
and saying are they congruent yes they
are congruent
okay all right so now that's related to
being able to say region congruent
here
of disk and disk is that correct
yes
okay
okay
what
it'll be fixed possible issue with the
merge and all the
you know prototype not stable
it should be concrete the identity
all right well so i mean it's just a bug
presumably yes
i mean is there anything going to work
here
okay
okay
so but
is anything going to work i mean is this
working
if you look at the example in the
documentation this is a basic rule
something is it's wrong in the code some
stuff you're you know tracing facing
down
what the heck is this wait a minute
this is a ridiculously complicated first
example no no no we we are working on
the documentation they are not yet
fine
okay so this example is absurdly
complicated
so you can take a rectangle and then you
can take a polygon right so and
the function should try to work and
figure that out i know but but if if
this had a parameter in it is it going
to give me the condition
yeah it should try to give you the
condition yes
um
okay
uh
all right now how does that relate to
what michael's geometric test does
would it give conditions or not
no
i i have a question to the new function
obviously the geometry test is
specialized for synthetic geometry in
the plane
you just said it gave no test i mean
gave no conditions it's good condition
okay it depends on how complicated the
example is
okay
so say you have two implicit regions one
with
less and one is less equal are they
congruent or not
sorry can you repeat that again
about open and closed regions yes
are they congruent is an open region
congruent to a closed
region um no in our case you that mean
there should be a map so if there is no
explicit map where you get the identity
at the end they shouldn't be congruent
okay
so
okay so i'm asking then again i mean do
we does it bother us that we have these
two functions that work like this no
explain why
i mean in other words you're saying you
consider these this is overlapping
functionality
where in the case of
geometric tests
right it has tons of tests region
congruent needs to work on all regions
not just some 2d regions i i don't care
do the name geometric tests well i don't
care either so doesn't say 2d regions
right i'm trying to understand just
because one was built by one team one
was built by another team the whole
point of these design reviews is to try
and make sure we don't end up with
something with crazy seams where you can
tell how the thing was built
well i think the the main key point so
so region congruent i don't think we
expect that you know in the next release
geometry test will work on nerves
yeah
so jump region congruent should work on
all geometric ways on nub
mesh right
so this is geometric test
is something which over the years might
eventually work on
you know a wider range of things
including 3d and so on although clearly
it will be different because because
clockwise isn't relevant to 3d
presumably
right
i mean
also let's a little bit keep the history
in mind geometric test we added after we
had geometric assumption because
geometric assumption we wanted to have a
pure statement that something is the
case we didn't want to test for it we
just want to say it should be so
uh so without any evaluation semantics
and then we add a test to then do the
corresponding checks
right
but so you see no conflict michael no
between geometric tests and this region
congruent i mean that's similar to what
we just discussed on monday in the in
the chemistry meeting like we have as
one of the sub-value properties of a
module the molecular
mass but yet we can have our own
function molecular mass that it's uh
fine
right i agree i agree i'm a bit you know
i think you it's a reasonable question
to ask i guess the answer is is
that
um
okay so then these functions all seem
like they're going to be okay are there
any are there any notable features of
these
that
roger do you want to highlight anything
about
of course what should not happen is that
they give different results
no because they are threatened by
different peoples that might maybe
dedicate no no no
i mean i think
that would be a bug of yours right but
but it's obviously a very good benchmark
to do
right if if they're inconsistent result
there is investigation needed right yes
the other thing i want to highlight is
region transform but i think that we
wanted to name it find region transform
that finds the actual mapping
this is the the one in e m
probably
look at find region transformers yeah
oh the old one is still left okay right
it finds a final science mod generally
what type of transformation is going to
find
right now we'll try it you will find a
fine transforms
okay
so no
no no scalings involved
yeah scaling is fine scaling is fine
okay daily is that fine
so similar in general there could be you
know a
conformal
you know some arbitrary conformal map
thing which this isn't doing
right i mean linear fractional would be
the next okay yeah you know level but
you know and and if you go
and at some point some
that it's not going to be dysfunction if
you want to find something way more
general
i think we don't even know yet
okay but but
so
most likely
fine region transform could eventually
have a third argument which says in what
space to try to find transforms
yes
but the default will be an affine
transform which is what it's doing right
now
right
okay and what it returns
is this transformation function
which can represent up to linear
fraction
you know linear fine linear fraction
but the input reacting in parallel.com
or exact object should it return
transformation function with the numbers
inside
good point
probably should be exact yeah i would
say so
and and can it deal with parameters or
not
i don't know charles
yes
it will work like everything else you
should you know if you have parameters
you should return with parameters we are
working on that
so it doesn't work yet
or does it work
does it work here
we should try
that's all i can say we are working on
that i mean it's a non-trivial problem
so it
that's a surprising thing but that's
okay wait
oh
what are the parameters to a
parallelogram
okay if i just give a vector will it
will it work
no oh well i have to go
okay zero zero zero followed by two
vectors in the list
the symbolic case is probably not in
this current build so we have to build
the whole process for symbolic only
okay
okay so what else do we want to look at
here so what is geometric transformation
these are old things these are things
that we introduced in version six which
are part of the graphics language what
we've now done is that we accept them
part of the geometry language
so okay and and so michael
rotate for example so so wait a minute
so if i say here for example
region congr okay so let's first of all
let's just say rotate
uh rectangle
30 degrees
oh that's funny
what i mean i know what that did but but
how do you turn that into a region
it is a region it's a region now so it's
what region of that is true
what's that
right so
what the heck is that
that is uh
unsimplified area exactly
i mean
it's correct but it's maybe not what you
would want
that's this new wfr anti-simplified that
probably has been applied
well
okay hold on
this is representing
this here
has a very bizarre print form
but
it's basically representing this rotated
rectangle so if i say for example if i
say region union
of percent 15 comma
let's say
uh i don't know rectangle
right and then
post process we'd slash regio okay
because you want to see the visual
okay fine
that's nice
this is a very weird thing though people
were very confused by the fact that that
produces that and yet it works
and i think that's actually also the
ambiguity because for example if you
replace the rectangle by mesh discretize
it then we return you a mesh so there's
also that
and essentially that's that you know
doctor evaluation i mean we don't
manipulate traffic primitive
keep them unevaluated
so this is discretized
graphics right
yes or discrete can i use discretized
region there as well yeah but it works
can you please run the full form of that
though because we can't tell just by
looking at that
oh you mean
although i guess this is this is fairly
um i mean i don't know of any other
places where rotate actually evaluates
to something although i mean it makes
sense that it does it here
what
do you mean something
yeah in this case if i say input form of
that
i think it makes perfect sense i mean
that it's just
i i don't know of any other place where
where it actually evaluates though
but yeah
and so
rotate works in 3d does it or not
yeah
yes
i mean not the full generality but
pretty general actually in 3d
okay
yeah yeah it has i didn't realize it it
adopted the whole thing
right
yeah okay all right well this seems fine
is there anything else that we should
look at with find
this is there's the numerical precision
business
what
of the find region transform business oh
yes what michael did you know
they didn't preserve it well
yeah that's not an issue
i mean okay
that's okay sorry what we're going to
say there's the whole issue of dot dot
what
me
you were just saying there's the whole
issue of in connection with find region
transform no no i said that that was it
that was that was the whole thing
okay so find region transform if the
thing is slightly distorted
what is its tolerance and does it have a
tolerance specification
we use the default system tolerance for
numbers right
we were talking about a problem with
that what was that problem
because there is oh no okay yes so there
is uh
there is a
fine transformation
the image
function between points
what is that
find geometric transform
what's the difference between that and
find geometric transfer and geometric
this is what we were discussing yes yes
yes okay so this relationship between
find region transform and find geometric
transform
so find geometric transform
you know actually does the fitting so
for a given set of of a point p1 to p2
it gives you the mapping the best fit of
a linear transform from p2 to p1
and what the heck is that thing there
so that's actually the error
because it's a pure fitting probe you
know function so it gives you the actual
error in you know you can actually
gosh
so find geometric transform and find
region transform do completely different
things
or do they both they both return
transformation
the goal at least both seem to have the
same goal which is to actually find a
mapping
between
two set point set or two-way job
represented by a transformation function
yes
but one does a fitting so you try to
approximate even though the input is not
i mean the mapping is not exact try to
approximate it
and find geometry transform actually
work on um other
sets
so essentially if you
you know if you give a set of points and
then you just you know apply a random
permutation you get different answer
where
find uh region transform this is a
geometrical function it doesn't actually
matter how you actually
give the set of points
wait a minute but if i'm trying to find
a transformation between two images
there's yet a different function is that
correct no there's no no
no it's the same function so what you do
for images is you get key points
okay and then
because the transformation convention
that we implemented for images it's
backwards
so i'm saying oh god do you remember
that
it it sort of goes backwards um
so this one returned a backwards
transformation oh
i mean because this function actually is
it makes sense for images it makes sense
for images but not for geometry
so except that this is called fine
geometric transformer but it applies to
images
yes
yes
okay i think we've got a mess on our
hands here
yeah let's go through what what the
things are
case one we've got a collection of
points it's a point cloud you're trying
to rotate the point cloud is that
correct
trying to find is this point cloud
related to this other point cloud by
rotation for example
is that right
yes
okay
case number two i've got two images
i want to find out you know if i take if
i say something like you know
image rotate
uh you know image of a
penguin
okay great
so that object there so if i say
what function will tell me
how that penguin is rotated
steven i think what he said earlier is
not quite right i think
fine geometric transform does not find
the transformation between two point
clouds but
between the points
of two point sets
so the order medals
yes
okay
can i find the transformation between
these two penguins
well you have to get key point you have
to get points first of all i see i see i
see so so this function geometric
transform only deals with lists of
points yes
i mean is there a function that deals
with images find geometric transform
work on images so if you try to give
them doesn't say that yeah
that's that's not right at all
okay so find geometric transform percent
24
and percent 25
what the heck is that okay so how do i
find out what that is actually doing how
do i apply that transformation function
to a rectangle
you can apply it to an image
because it has the right okay okay so
then i say
percent sub 2 for some bizarre reason
apply that to percent 25.
what happened you have to use image
transformation yeah you have to yeah
why would why wouldn't that work
i mean maybe you can make the argument
because it doesn't know whether to do a
forward or reverse transform
but that's it music is basically
image yeah
okay so what what happens here i say
image transformation and then i give the
transformation there think image
command f
okay
no wrong wrong place
yeah how much you put into post in the
image in the transformation function
image chance
just just place it there and then a
comma
yes thank you
maybe this is the reverse of what we
think it is
the black hole um
okay so look we've got we've got i kind
of think that this should work and
there's probably should be examples down
there so i'm a little bit unsure of if
there's something temporary with uh
the the prototype this doesn't give any
examples here this is a not very well
documented thing
okay we have no idea how to reapply this
okay so we've got
multiple things and i have to go in a
moment here so we've got multiple things
going on we've got
find geometric transform which
deals with lists of points
we've got
find geometric transform
region transform yeah
no we're sorry geometric
moment we've got fine region transform
which deals with regions
yes
then we've got the older find geometric
transform which deals with points and
images
right
we only have two
no we've got two we got the new find
region transform we've got the old fine
geometric transform
but there are three types of things on
which those operate
point lists
images and region specifications
correct
yes yes
okay
currently find geometric transform
operates on point lists and reach an
image specification images
right whereas find region transform
operates only on regions is that correct
yes
it does not operate on point lists it
does no it does
or is it point like this one in other
words can i take this example here
right go from this example here
yes
and say find geometric transform okay
and now i say oh god this is a mess guys
but it's a region they
you know we don't care about the order
of the point where find geometry
transform they have to be ordered okay
well that's an interesting difference
and this insane thing that this returns
that as its first argument
not really insane is a fitting function
i mean like minimum exactly the fitting
function so you return the error
you turn the minimum
this is this you want to minimize the
error and this is the minimum and you
want to know how good it is
okay so you guys believe that find
geometric transform and find region
transform
are consistent is that true
even though the transformation functions
given here are utterly different
possibly one is the inverse of the other
i don't know
can i apply one transformation function
to the other we need to clarify a little
bit more clearly so that the
relationship this would be properties
and relations how they relate i know
i don't know why doesn't that work
yeah composition we have a function
function for that composition
is this going to work yes
what's it going to do is it going to
show their inverses
it's going to show the composition of
those two functions which is a new
transformation function
what the heck is the relationship
between these two
what is the relationship between them
right
so first find geometry transform it's
actually looking at the bigger space in
this case like you see that it's
returning a specific transom linear
transformation right because you see
that you have a denominator so it's look
at for look at the larger range set
refine region transform just limit
itself to a fine transform right but if
you actually so in principle if you give
you know
a other s
point set
to find your matrix transform and then
you take that same values that same
number and give it to
find region transform
you should actually get
the invest transformation so they should
coincide if it's exact
we have to wrap up here unfortunately i
have to go
um i don't think we're quite finished
here
i think we need to you guys should
do
one more investigation of the
relationship between
find geometric transform and find region
transform
and then
you know if we've got a crisp answer to
that and how those relate to images then
we should be able to take care of this
in like 10 minutes
make sense
okay
all right
disappearing all right see you guys soon
thank you